what made you want to stop drinking  um i guess a mixture of like getting fit  getting healthy for one but also just  like  um anxiety and like [ __ ] depression  everything it smiles everything out of  control so like  and then i don't know if it was becoming  an issue or like i mean it's kind of  your guys's brand too right it's like if  you  if you're out with the guys it's like oh  yeah  every fan he meets like chug this beer  take this shot [ __ ]  it's it's like the way i look at it too  is like if i'm quitting drinking for a  bit  it's not serious but like if you're  quitting heroin you don't go hang out  with a bunch of  people doing heroin you know i mean like  you you gotta go  change people you surround yourself with  and that's pretty much  another part that i just did just like  might as well surround myself with  people  and things that are like positive for  where i'm like mentally going